let's guess tonight co-created and  starred and then when a ward winning  Comedy Central show key and Peele now  he's making his Broadway debut in the  new Steve Martin play meteor shower  let's give it up for keegan-michael key  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  yeah that's an entrance entrance good  god I hope you are wearing your Fitbit  3,000 sit-ups credible it's your first  time on the Apollo my first time ever on  the holiday I can't believe it  in one year and one year I get to be on  abroad and my Broadway debut and I get  to be at the Apollo I can't it's like my  cup runneth over thanks  [Applause]  you